Hank: Good morning, John.
I live in a small town in Montana, where I
have several times been asked if I am interested
in running for local election.
As a local business owner and a semi-celebrity
and a person who is very good at picking karaoke
songs, I would have an okay chance of winning.
But what pops into my mind every time someone
asks me this question is that I'm not really
from Missoula, Montana, I'm from the internet.
Now that raises some interesting questions
about like, the concept of place and the future
of local government and the future of the
autonomy of the internet, but those are big,
abstract questions.
The more pressing one is if internet citizenship
exists, then are there some things that we
could be doing to be better internet citizens?
I think yes.
And here is my first crack at some guidelines.
People on the internet are people.
The internet is real life.
Treat people like people online or off.
Every person is complicated and impossible
to fully understand.
If you think you've got somebody pegged completely
after reading a 25 word comment, you're wrong.
Removing comments and communities that dehumanize
or mock other people is not censorship, it's
kindness.
Everybody can see and read the stuff that
you put on the internet, and it will probably
be there pretty much forever, so be thoughtful.
BS detection is one of the most crucial skills
of the online citizen, and it takes a long
time to develop that set of skills.
In fact, it's something that I think should
be taught in schools everywhere.
The number one rule, though?
Cite your sources and don't share statistics
that you can't find sources for.
Just because something seems like it's true
does not mean it is.
And in general, don't share things that might
be lies, even if they help you make a point
that is really important to make.
Mark Twain said it best, of course, "A lie
can travel halfway round the world while the
truth is putting on its shoes.
Don't be part of the problem, help the truth
put its shoes on."
You don't know everything.
Nobody does.
Nobody even knows most things.
Don't steal stuff from creators and then repost
it without attribution.
Do, however, attempt to source unsourced content
by using reverse image search engines like
TinEye.
Not only is this good internet citizenship,
it's also a great way to hone your research
skills.
Anyone can edit Wikipedia, for real.
If you see a grammatical or spelling mistake,
go ahead and fix it.
If you find a vandalized page, you can fix
that by going to the page history, finding
the change that introduced the vandalism,
and then clicking undo.
It's that simple.
If you'd like to do more than just fix small
errors and vandalism on Wikipedia articles,
you can read more about the philosophy and
strategies of the serious Wikipedia editor
before you start to actually make big changes.
And in general, if you're joining any new
online community of people doing something
together or enjoying something together, recognize
that there are probably going to be some rules
that you do not yet know, and that you're
probably going to make some early mistakes.
And if you are part of one of those existing
communities and new people come in, expect
that they're not gonna know all the rules,
and they are gonna make some mistakes.
And finally, don't expect that everyone or
even you is going to be able to follow all
of these rules all of the time.
Sometimes, we get angry.
Sometimes, we all act like jerks.
Be understanding of yourself and be understanding
of others.
When I asked Twitter and Tumblr what the most
important rules of internet citizenship were,
a lot of people pointed me toward Wheaton's
Law, which I like, but is a little bit subjective.
Reworded slightly for the families out there,
Wheaton's Law is basically just "Don't be
a jerk."
But the response I liked most went further
than that.
"Always leave people and places better than
the way that you found them."
That's what we should be working for in this
wonderful place that has, in many ways, become
my home.
John, I'll see you on Tuesday.
The second episode of Dear Hank and John,
our new podcast, is out and online now.
We're gonna try and have one every single
week coming out like, Sunday or Mondayish.
People seem to be liking it.
Here are some Tweets that we didn't even solicit.
"Dear Hank and John is such a funny awesome
podcast, laughing silently on the bus."
"Dear Hank and John is gold!"
"Hank and John's podcast may be the greatest
thing ever.
Commutes just got a whole lot better."
"This new podcast and Cereal Time have been
the highlights of my June.
I really don't see it getting any better than
this.
Thank you."
Which brings up the fact that Cereal Time
has been going now for a week, a little more
than a week, and I love it.
Also Titansgrave is still happening, and it's
so funny, I love it, I mean, it's just me,
I--like, it's me being a dork with my dork
friends, but it's great.
You can find links to how to get to Dear Hank
and John and all those other things in the
description below.
Thanks for watching.
DFTBA.